[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce premier
set 8 culture de la saison tout de suite
le sommaire retour sur l'ouverture de la
troisième saison de la commanderie arts
visuels spectacles de danse ou encore
poésie de nombreuses animations étaient
prévues pour ravir petits et grands
focus sur l'exposition épopée
mansonnienne 22 oeuvres sont à découvrir
elles représentent des personnalités de
l'histoire de maisons laffitte
l'artiste c215 nous parlera de son
travail
coup d'envoi des halls factory ce week
end au programme de l'événement jacob
desvarieux les ogres de barback ou
encore daniel zimmermann de nombreux
concerts sont à découvrir et je vous le
disais en titre le coup d'envoi de la
troisième saison culturelle de la
commanderie a lieu ce samedi 12
septembre elle en cours la manifestation
s'est déroulée dans une ambiance
conviviale arts visuels poésie et si on
s'était à l'honneur via des animations
un reportage de nicolas landry et
bixente merrien arts visuels spectacle
de danse poésie expériences
scientifiques
quatre axes du programme culturel de la
commanderie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
mise en avant lors de la soirée
d'inauguration celui incarne à la fois
une dimension historique importante
c'est un lieu emblématique pour
l'agglomération et en même temps il se
veut
accompagné l'émission culturelle pour la
saison qui s'annonce c'est un espèce de
lieux privilégiés à part dans la ville
sur le territoire où on laisse quasiment
le décor extérieur à l'extérieur et on
est dans un autre lieu qui est un lieu
d'art et ça c'est magique et c'est rare
une soirée d'inauguration point de
départ d'une saison qui s'annonce riche
les moments forts le premier qui me
vient à l'idée ce sera les journées de
la science important très importante
parce que là la mission science et est
importante notamment pour les enfants
et puis l'autre événement un autre
événement de grande convivialité qui
sera le noël des cas les voilà au mois
de décembre
en attendant c'est un moment chaleureux
et festif qui a été proposé aux saint
quentinois 450 personnes ont répondu
présent à l'appel malgré les
restrictions sanitaires en vigueur
là encore à saint quentin en yvelines la
culture entre en résistance face au co
vide les espaces se sont remplis les
publics vont et viennent donc on est
très heureux il y à tous les âges sont
représentés
donc c'était vraiment notre ambition de
pouvoir réunir les familles et puis
toutes les générations
prochain rendez vous les journées
européennes du patrimoine les 19 et 27
ans un événement qui marque le début
d'une année riche en temps forts
culturels
le premier aura lieu justement le samedi
3 octobre à 20 heures à minuit la
commanderie ouvrira ses portes pour
l'annuelle nuit blanche au programme
installation vidéo oeuvres interactives
ou encore accro danse l'entrée est
gratuite
vendredi la septième édition de
totalement désarçonné a été lancé pour
l'occasion l'artiste urbain c215 est
venu présenter son exposition épopée
mansonnienne au château de maisons
laffitte
une exposition en partenariat avec la
ville et les monuments nationaux un
reportage d'astrid bergère avec et
xavier jaglin 22 c'est le nombre
d'oeuvres peintes par l'artiste c215
pour son exposition épopée mentionné
yens louis xiv louise
ou encore voltaire ils représentent des
personnalités liées à l'histoire de
maisons laffitte
il ya des maréchaux d'empiré il ya des
acteurs des sportifs des romanciers un
philosophe
voilà donc c'est aussi des portraits qui
remontent pour les plus anciens jusqu'au
xviie siècle avec la fondation du
château avec anne d'autriche et louis
xiii et qui font remonter jusqu'à le
plus récent c'est grégory baugé qui est
un donc un cycliste qui est champion
olympique
les supports utilisés sont divers livres
chaise ou encore murs de la ville
les portraits ont été réalisés au
pochoir technique de prédilection de
l'artiste
ma spécialité c'est de peindre des
pochoirs dans la rue ou sur des objets
c'est aussi la dimension insolite de
l'expo il ya beaucoup d'interactions
avec les objets c'est toujours des
oeuvres contextuel qui tendent à se
fondre un peu dans l'environnement mais
qui se détachera pas dès qu'on les
remarque en fait donc c'est pas
spécialement des oeuvres qui s'impose à
la vue aussi bien dans le château cos
dehors mais qui lorsqu'on les remarques
ensuite seuls resteront en fait une
partie des portraits présente dans les
différentes pièces du château l'autre
dont la ville à travers un parcours
urbain l'art dans la ville c'est la vie
même dans la ville est donc une ville
vit avec des associations etc mais doit
vivre également avec des oeuvres
artistiques et ce soir c'est 215 a mis
quelques pochoir dans la ville avec des
gens célèbres qui ont fait notre ville
nous sommes les héritiers d'une longue
lignée dailleux lirait breslau les
portraits exposés à l'intérieur du
château sont à découvrir jusqu'au 30
novembre
et parmi les autres expositions à
découvrir d'alésia à rome la
manifestation retrace l'aventuré
archéologique de napoléon
elle est à découvrir du 19 septembre au
3 janvier 2021
les artistes bernard prat et à nakache
exposé à la maison elsa triolet aragon
au programme sculpture couture ou encore
photographie l'événement a lieu jusqu'au
29 novembre
et puis au centre alfred de vigny
hypo la dominguez présente expérience
dans un cirque tzigane l'exposition est
visible jusqu'au 1er octobre
ce week end la deuxième édition du
festival et hall à mantes-la-jolie
accueillera une vingtaine deux concerts
au programme de l'événement jacob
desvarieux les ogres de barback ou
encore daniel zimmermann à nos belles
nous parle de l'événement sur ce bassin
d'auby il ya eu énormément de facteurs
d'instruments qui seront installés et
d'artisans autour de la facture
d'instruments et donc la facture
instrumentale donc ça c'est assez
développée à partir du 19ème siècle
viola faire un festival sur le lieu de
la création d'instruments
c'est important pour nous pour les
musiciens et on l'espère pour le public
on n'est pas sur un festival de jazz on
n'est pas sur un festival de musiques
actuelles on est vraiment semant un
festival de musique puisque on mélange
musiques actuelles jazz n chaise dits
classiques et parfois même sur le même
concert avec des rencontres assez
incroyable on a la chance d'avoir trois
créations dans le cadre de son festival
donc évidemment nathalie d'auxerre avec
du club espace vendredi on aura aussi
jacob desvarieux ses amis et les
musiques au pays
le samedi et on aura également une
création de clémentine de couture qui
est une chanteuse doit de d'opéra et de
musique classique le fdl factory
festival lui continue jusqu'au 11
octobre et met en avant elles les
talents locaux
parmi les temps forts de ce mois festif
on retrouve le groupe metro kabar il
sera en concert le 2 octobre à 20 heures
au chapiteau de chanteloup les vignes et
c'est le retour du festival l'estival
qui revient pour sa 33e édition à partir
du 18 septembre le festival de musique
est dédié à la chanson francophone
proposera une programmation d'une 20
ten d'artistes pour en parler avec nous
sur ce plateau célia gap son god of war
fait lire bon soir alors il paraît que
ça va être une édition un peu
particulière puisqu'elle se fera à
masquer mais les organisateurs
souhaitait avant tout que le festival
soit maintenu et ses chaussettes
il débutera ce vendredi avec deux
concerts gratuits la coordinatrice du
festival nous en parle
cette année le premier week-end en offre
deux concerts au saint germanois et à
ceux qui viennent prendre des places
c'est un spectacle de renaud hantson
mais dans son spectacle hommage à michel
berger donc il va interpréter les plus
grandes chansons michel berger et le
samedi 19 ça c'est vendredi 18 et samedi
on a un grand spectacle familial avec
alain schneider à 17 heures pour que les
familles puissent sortir
alors cette année la programmation est
très varié le 26 septembre les frangines
se produiront sur la scène du théâtre
alexandre dumas elles se sont fait
connaître notamment par ce clip où elle
chante leurs chansons donnez-moi sur un
bateau
[Musique]
acer
à quoi on les honore
même pas si je t'aime
m
[Musique]
vendredi 2 octobre c'est le jeune
artiste fuseau qui devrait interpréter
son titre love notamment puis les
goguettes qui ont fait un carton durant
le confinement je sais pas si vous vous
en souvenez ils ont repris le titre
vesoul de jacques brel
t'as voulu voir le salon et on a vu le
saluer ta ble voir la chambre et on a vu
la chambre et bien ce groupe montera sur
la scène pour détourner de nombreux
autres chansons françaises et puis dans
un tout autre registre salvatore adamo
viendra chanter le samedi 3 octobre ses
plus grands tubes et ce festival célia
c'est aussi une façon de relancer la
culture à saint germain en laye oui
puisque cela faisait un moment que la
culture comme dans d'autres villes
étaient à l'arrêt il y avait un
véritable besoin de faire revivre
l'aviculture culturelles et musicales
les souhaits de regarder des artistes
sur son écran mais c'est pas du tout
pareil que de les vivre en live
donc on a cherché tous les moyens pour
le faire dans la plus grande sécurité
pour tout le monde
alors forcément le masque sera
obligatoire tout au long des spectacles
du gel hydroalcoolique sera fournie à
l'entrée et il n'y aura pas de barre
pour les entractes le festival mettra en
lumière comme chaque année une
association caritative
et cette année c'est le lion sedan t1
une antenne du lion ce club pour
soutenir la recherche sur la trisomie 21
parfait merci beaucoup c'est lien vous
retrouve dans le prochain 7,8 culture
avec kadir et le théâtre fait sa rentrée
également avec un week-end de trois
jours sous le thème les retrouvailles ça
se fait dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine mais aussi pour marquer
l'ouverture de la saison le théâtre vous
propose plusieurs événements gratuits
sur réservation
le week end et luttera avec le concert
de 30 kabar groupe de musique maloya
ce sera le vendredi à 18 septembre à 20h
le samedi vous pourrez découvrir saint
quentin en yvelines sous un autre angle
une visite qui aidera de laiton des
rousses hier jusqu'à l'étang de saint
quentin donc et lionel hamas était le
directeur du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement nous
en parle on est passé une commande à une
compagnie qui s'appelle de façon
extrêmement politique la mp une agence
nationale de psychanalyse urbaine qui a
pour habitude de psychanalyse et les
villes c'est à dire de voir quels sont
les
point de friction qu'elles sont toutes
ces choses qui sont cachés et que l'on
ne veut pas voir
ils sont restés dix jours sur le
territoire au mois de février dernier
qui a rencontré les historiens locaux
des urbanistes des architectes qui avait
participé à la conception de cette ville
il ya maintenant quelques quelques
décennies avec cet ensemble
d'informations exemple construit une
visite qui va durer deux ou trois heures
donc il faut que les spectateurs les
sages en marché 2,3 km où ils vont
essayer de révéler des choses que l'on
voit tous les jours que l'on a sous les
yeux tous les jours mais que l'on ne
voit pas à noter que des visites du
théâtre seront organisées samedi et
dimanche
en partenariat avec l'âme humaine le
musée et la médiathèque et de saint
quentin en yvelines et c'est la fin de
ce premier set 8 culture merci de nous
avoir suivi et on se retrouve à la
semaine prochaine pour de nouveaux
rendez vous culturel et d'ici là portez
vous bien
[Musique]
oh